في اخبار المعركه في اوكرانيا قال المتحدث
باسم قوات الغرب في الجيش الروسي سركيز
بنسكي ان القوات الروسيه سيطرت على مواقع
علي القوات الاوكرانيه في اتجاه كوبيانس
واضاف ان القوات الروسيه صدت هجمات
اوكرانيه في نوفوس
في سياق الاعمال الهجوميه في اتجاه
كوبيانسك سيطرت قواتنا على اربعه معاقل
وخمسه مراكز مراقبه ومركز ذخيره وهزمت
سريه مشاه اوكرانيه في منطقه مانكوفكا
وتسطينا لتسع هجمات نفذتها وحدات من
اللواء الميكانيكي التابع للقوات
الاوكرانيه على مواقعنا في سينكوفكا
ومانكوفكا كما دمرت قوات المدفعيه الروسيه
وحده للمشاه وعددا من الاليات الاوكرانيه
اثناء هجوم على مواقع قواتنا في نوفو
وقالت وكاله اوتاس ان الجيش الاوكراني
حاول مهاجمه مواقع تخزين الوقود النووي
المستهلك في محطه النوويه التي تسيطر
عليها روسيا جنوبيه اوكرانيا قالت الوكاله
ان القوات الروسيه اعترضت طائره مسيره
هجوميه في في حيث محطه النوويه وان تحليل
مسارها اظهر انها كانت تتجه الى منشاه
تخزين الوقود النووي المستهلك وهو امر قد
يؤدي لو حدث الى كارثه نوويه بحسب الوكاله
وقال مستشار الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ميخائيل
بودياك ان الهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاد مازال
مستمرا وان على الجميع ان يتحلى بالصبر
واشار الى انه بنهايه المهام العسكريه
التي ينفذها الجيش الاوكراني لن تضل روسيا
تشكل تهديدا عسكريا لاوروبا واوكرانيا حسب
قوله
من جانب اخر قال وزير الدفاع الروسي
تخطط الانشاء وحدات عسكريه بولنديه
اوكرانيه لاحتلال غربيه اوكرانيا لاحقا
واضاف ان نحو 30000 عسكري والاف المعدات
العسكريه قد حشدت قرب حدود روسيا
وبيلاروسيا غربا مشيرا الى ان النيتو
والغرب قدموا مساعدات لاوكرانيا تزيد
قيمتها عن 160 مليار دولار
بالقرب من حدود دوله الاتحاد يتمركز تجمع
من القوات يضم حوالي 360 الف عسكري
وثمانيه الاف مصفحه وسته الاف منظومه
مدفعيه وقاذفه الغام عدد افراد تشكيلات
الدول غير الاقليميه في حلف شمال الاطلسي
ارتفع بنسبه اثنين ونصف منذ فبراير من
العام الماضي وتجاوز 30 الف شخص المخاطر
الحاليه ترتبط بعسكره بولندا التي اصبحت
الاداه الرئيسيه لسياسه الولايات المتحده
المناهضه لروسيا
وفي بولندا وافقت وزاره الدفاع على ارسال
قوات اضافيه الى الحدود مع بيلاروسيا بناء
على طلب من حرس الحدود وكان نائب وزير
الداخليه قال امثله اثنين ان حرس الحدود
طلب من وزاره الدفاع ارسال الف جنديا
اضافي الى الحدود وسط زياده في محاولات
عبور الحدود بشكل غير قانوني وتاتي الخطوه
بعد ظهور مقاتلين تابعين لمجموعه فاغنر
قرب الحدود في تطور وصفته وارسو بانه يهدف
لزعزعه لزعزعه الاوضاع في الجناح الشرقي
للنيتو